un cd à 5 euros une tablette numérique à
200 euros qui dirait non depuis lundi
matin virgin placée en redressement
judiciaire mi janvier à brader
l'ensemble de ses produits excepté les
livres avec des remises de 50 % et même
70% avec la carte de fidélité et pour le
plus grand bonheur des clients qui ont
dévalisé les magasins des fournitures
pour la future rentrée scolaire stylos
cahiers que ces thérapies un peu des
petits gadgets
moi je me suis fait trop virgin dans son
grand quelques jeux vidéo et puis de
trois séries animées victime de son
succès la firme a dû arrêter brutalement
sa braderie ce mercredi à 18h
à part quelques atouts selon les
syndicats la direction aurait assuré aux
salariés que les bénéfices de ces seuls
dire est au budget du plan social de la
firme qui vise 700 employés sur 960 une
éventuelle reprise de virgin permettrait
de sauver huit magasins selon les
syndicats mais l'enseigne de montigny le
bretonneux devrait fermer ses portes
hammerson le bailleur propriétaire du
groupe skywest qui ne souhaite pas
communiquer seraient opposés à la
négociation
les candidats potentiels ont jusqu'au 23
mai pour se faire connaître
date de l'audience au tribunal de
commerce de paris